this is a production of Cornell
University
so one of the great things about
high-throughput plant phenotyping is
from the plant breeding side is we've
been thinking about how to put
phenotyping for quite a few years but
plant breeders themselves have been
doing phenotyping for the past 10,000
years and they've tried to get plants to
to feed and clothe the world and provide
food fuel and feed thankfully not all
lamb breeders evolve at such a slow rate
over the past 10,000 years and we
quickly have realized that there is a
lot of tremendous technologies that can
be applied through our field of plant
breeding and it's in a sense forcing us
to think more broadly into computer
science engineering robotics and
artificial intelligence
so this compose iam I feel isn't just
for Plant Sciences themselves but it
really is also an opportunity for us to
reach out to other departments on campus
and for them to see the value of our
work and how they can fit into that plan
so our first talk today is going to be
by Todd Dhawan he is from one of the
best phenotyping companies in the world
and the title of his presentation is
phenotyping solutions for basic and
applied research in plant biology and
agriculture
alright so great all right well thank
you very much and thank you Oh Lina for
the invitation I think we started this
conversation a couple of months ago or
six weeks or so ago and it's really nice
to be able to follow it up so quickly I
really appreciate that
speed speed is so important and
area of endeavor so I'm going to be
talking to you about phenotyping
solutions for poor plant biology and how
you can apply them to agricultural
research applications I'm coming at this
from the perspective of today being the
business development lead for a
technology company that's developing
solutions in this space but my
background is prior to that I spent 11
years working with Monsanto and
specifically my my last role with
Monsanto before I left the company in
September was a strategy lead for a
precision phenotyping system that they
had developed that they constructed in
Research Triangle Park and prior to that
was working with paradigm genetics and
we were working on what we call the gene
function Factory in Arabidopsis between
2000 and 2005 where we were doing a lot
of high-throughput phenotyping and
Arabidopsis so while I'm pitching a
product if that's the right thing to say
today while I'm here representing Lemna
tech I'm also I also have a pretty
expensive background in the in the
application side of things so I'll start
out a little bit just echoing what Mike
said about the history and talk a little
bit about the challenges coming
primarily from the genomic side of
things won't talk too much about the
environment but of course G by E is
crucial to anything that you do in the
phenotyping space and then I'll shift
from there and talk a little bit about
technologies that we're developing at
Lemna tech and and how they address some
of the solutions to those challenges
that we're facing as as researchers so
just to echo what Mike said we have been
phenotyping for 10,000 years actually
phenotyping was one of the key things
that came out of the Neolithic
Revolution as we domesticated species so
as a as a dog lover and as a
- or an occasional homebrewer of beer
fermentation and domestication of
animals also came out of the Neolithic
Revolution so I feel like dog lovers
beer brewing and phenotyping should all
coincide as an appreciation for what
Neolithic man gave us today but you know
it's really impressive when we look at
when we look at the history of
phenotyping over the last nine thousand
years when you consider what teosinte is
and what it has become with with field
corn today but what's even more
impressive is that is that that idea of
speed has and how that has accelerated
in the last 50 to 75 years so if you
look at breeding gained gains in in corn
for example if you look at where we were
back and around 1920 before the advent
of hybridization in corn it took a land
area about the equivalent of a half
quart of basketball court to produce one
bushel of corn through hybridization and
impressive gain impressive gains and
yield through breeding and then with the
advent of biotechnology in the late 90s
which really diddled has done a lot to
protect those breeding gains on corn
acreage today we are at about a land
area equivalent for a bushel of corn
that is equivalent to the space within
the free-throw Lane so between the
free-throw line and the out of bounds
that's about how much land area it takes
to produce bushel corn today so think
about that reduction in space and what
that's and the impact that that's the
positive impact that that's really had
on productivity and ability to to use a
land as we feed a growing population and
we're projected to get even to produce
uneven produce an equivalent bushel on
even
take courage as we move forward so
Mendel is considered the father of
genetics I think he's also foundational
in phenotyping and we can really trace
our ideas of phenotyping and features
that we're characterizing in plant
growth and development back to that of
those observational studies that that
Mendel had with peas and everything that
everything that he was looking at
genetically he was describing as as a
phenotype so phenotype is really
critical for explaining genetic outcomes
and no matter how we modify the genome
the desired outcome always occurs at the
level of the phenome so whether you're
whether you're looking at traditional
breeding outcomes like Mendel was doing
or whether you're looking at
non-mendelian inheritance through
epigenetics or other types of
modification through proto flap
protoplast fusion or mutagenesis
transgenesis polyploidy and just
recently we there have been a number of
products that have been released on the
market that are that are the first
generation products of gene editing so
the Browning resistant mushrooms is one
example of that so no matter how we
modify the genome we always want to see
what's happening at the at the level of
the phenome and the ability to modify
the genome the precision with which we
can modify the phenome the cost of
modifying the genome these are all these
are all becoming more and more these
you're all making genome modification
more and more accessible so not only
industry but also plant biology
researchers and and so the scale of
genome modification is increasing so
this is just reflecting some some graphs
and that I'm sure all of you have seen
that all of you have seen over the
recent
decade but the cost of sequencing
actually is moving faster than the
decrease in cost of computational power
by by Moore's law so we're three billion
dollars was spent to sequence the human
genome in the late 90s you can now do it
for about a thousand which is pretty
incredible
and as genome sequencing costs go down
of course the amount of sequencing data
that we accumulate increases so we're up
to the hundreds of trillions of base
pairs in GenBank today and similarly as
the cost of sequencing goes down at
Jason technologies like gene synthesis
are also coming down so all of this is
pointing to our ability to accelerate
genome modification and the real demand
to meet that to meet that acceleration
and genome modification with
corresponding increases and advancements
in genomics technology so I want to talk
a little bit about that and I put this
slide together sort of to editorialize
some ideas that I've been thinking about
over the past six months since I've been
with Lemna tech and I've been talking to
customers and I've been talking to
people in the US and Western Europe
about the about the about sort of the
state of where academia and industry are
with phenotyping and I tried to do sort
of a manual Spotfire Tory type view of
the of my of my thinking on this but I
want to I want to first talk about first
talk about the size of these bubbles
that I'm showing on the scratch on this
slide and the size is what I've done is
really kind of taken size to represent
utility and one of the things that I
hear a lot when I talk to people about
phenotyping is a lot of interest that
you know almost one of the first things
that that that come up our interest
areas in
these smaller bubbles the NIR infrared
chlorophyll fluorescence fluorescence in
general as a phenotyping technology but
what I what I will say is in my
experience and in and what real-world
needs really is about 80 to 85% of the
questions that you ask will rely on
high-resolution reliable repeatable
visible light imaging that's always
going to be the cornerstone of your
phenotyping of your phenotyping inquiry
there have been some really impressive
there have been some really impressive
advances in technology and capabilities
in the last decade or two 3d laser
scanning is another really useful tool
in for phenotyping it it uses it uses a
laser based approach to give you a very
detailed three-dimensional
reconstruction of the plants that you're
using and I'll talk about this now I may
repeat it again later but one of the
really powerful things that 3d laser
scanning brings to phenotyping is its
ability to make to make it bring
information forward from some of these
other from other these some of these
other systems so at Lemna Tech we use
data analytical approach called sensor
fusion where we take the 3d image of a
3d laser scan and overlay it on the 2d
images that are produced through for
example a chlorophyll fluorescence
system or an NIR system and what that
does is it it corrects for many of the
angle effects and confusion frankly in
the data that you get from a strictly 2d
image alone from some of these other
modalities so so 3d laser scanning has
has very high utility and then finally
hyperspectral is just there's a lot of
really exciting things happening
with hyperspectral imaging so from field
scanning using hyperspectral to do
scouting early detection of disease as
well as taking it into the laboratory
context so there's a group out of the
University of Bonn who's using hyper
spectral imaging to study metabolic and
and other chemical compositional changes
in plants so there's a lot of real
discovery phase things that are
happening with with hyper spectral
imaging now these days so that's the
size of the bubble and then the and then
as you're thinking about cost and these
this is all very subjective so working
in tens of thousands and you know we're
working in orders of magnitude not
specific numbers here but in terms of
cost visible light phenotyping is by far
going to be sort of your entry level
solution for coming in in the five to
twenty thousand dollar range for a very
nice instrumentation then laser scanning
you start getting up into you know the
ten to seventy thousand dollar range and
it's very easy to spend over a hundred
thousand dollars on hyper spectral on
high-end hyperspectral camera cameras so
just some things to keep in mind as
you're thinking about developing
phenotyping solutions I think more than
anything think about the kinds of
questions that you're asking now and
thinking think about the growth
potential of the system so how you can
how you can build on it as your as your
needs change going forward so I'm going
to take this and take some of these
ideas and talk about I think just given
the time I'll probably talk a little bit
about visible light imaging how we're
using it as some of the tools we've
developed at Lema tech show you how
we're using laser scanning and then talk
about a new instrument that we've
developed for hyperspectral imaging and
then see where we are
jump to the end so as I said visible
light imaging is really the cornerstone
of any phenotyping
system that you that you put in place
visible light imaging is going to
deliver the information that you need
for plant size plant architecture color
and if it's a very high quality system
you can get a very high degree of
temporal resolution so you can start
looking at change over time and then you
can use analytical solutions that I
think Chris will talk to you more about
to to do things like looking at
skeletonization to define leaf number
leaf length angles stem length
elongation rates change over time you
can you can use color to quantify very
specific features so you can get and you
can get an early view of damage either
due to herbicide or disease or or
abiotic stress whatever your question is
using using color and you can correlate
some of those color changes with
specific with specific responses so for
example you get a very different color
response in a rapid ops a Sun or
nitrogen stress than you do drought
stress you can extend it further beyond
plants to do to to insect feeding assay
so this is something that a number of
our industrial partners use our systems
for they use it for insects feeding
assays with dietary plates or even leaf
disks and then finally you can use
visible light imaging to get a lot of
information around around post-harvest
questions so looking at things like at
your metrics tip void kernel kahut doing
an estimate of total kernel count
individual seed metrics you can get
information about color and some
compositional features based on how
color how color changes over the course
over the dimensions of the seed so
essentially all of our systems whether
it's a laboratory field or greenhouse
system are all going to have visible
light imaging
as the foundation of the instrumentation
I'm just showing three examples of some
of our instruments here so on the left
here this is a this is a manual
individual plant phenotyping system
actually you can also do flats in the
top down version of this of this
instrument so you could do multiple
plants but it's essentially used it's a
it's an entry level system that's used
for low throughput phenotyping of
individual flats or plants it's got its
a standalone system with touchscreen
touchscreen control that also allows you
to do on-the-fly data visualization and
it's available as I'm showing here for
top-down view but we also have a short
wide one that's that you can use for
side view so if you're looking at taller
plants and especially for monocot softn
you want to have that side view imaging
up here at the top is that is a new
system that we're developing this year
it's it's really kind of a thing covet
as sort of a kind as a as an entry-level
automated phenotyping solution so you
can buy the the base unit that you see
here with only visible light imaging and
you can start immediately doing high
throughput phenotyping of flats of
plants or microtiter plates or whatever
your whatever your research area it
calls for and you can you can then it's
modular in the sense that you can start
adding on a tray feeder if your
throughput increases you can also add on
other imaging units if your imaging
demands increase so that you can start
expanding beyond visible light into
things like chlorophyll fluorescence or
hyperspectral and then finally down here
is just a picture of conveyor system
again visible light is part of all of
those systems and these systems are
larger greenhouse installations that
have fully integrated growth and plant
growth and they
it's and watering and so forth in them
3d laser scanning the way this works is
you use a laser to generate a point
cloud and so those point clouds identify
very specific features and you can do
this at a high degree of resolution and
use machine learning type of perches to
take those features that you're
extracting via the point clouds and
start using machine learning to identify
specific organ level features panicles
leaves things like that on the plant we
have so I just want to give you an
example of how we're using 3d laser
scanning in our field scan eliezer
system so this is a system that is at
the at University of Arizona Maricopa
field site and this is part of the Terra
reference project and a major focus of
this project is accelerating breeding in
bioenergy
sorghum for a to produce bioenergy
circum as a commodity crop for the
southeastern region of the United States
and we have many sensors within the
sensor box that we use at the Maricopa
site laser scanners are are an important
part of this and as I said before what
the laser scanners allow us to do is
that sensor fusion approach by coupling
the 3d view that we generate from laser
scanning with the 2d views of infrared
ps2 and hyper spec what I just want to
show here is a view of what that looks
like so this is data that was actually
captured over time from the Maricopa
field site and there's a couple of
things that I want to point out with
this first of all we're getting to the
point with with laser scanning and 3d
imaging with laser scanning that from a
gantry system we can singulate plan so
this was overtime and we were able to
monitor the growth of
these sets of plants individually over
time now the other thing that you can
see is the lasers the 3d images give you
a very that you can start seeing very
distinct architectural differences
between these two plots so let's just
focus on an easy one you can see that
there's very very different panicle
density between the one on the left and
the one on the right so that you can
start identifying very specific features
one of the things that we're working on
is to try to get laser scanning the load
try trying to get further down into the
canopy so while those are two of the
strengths one of the drawbacks is with
3d laser scanning from a gantry you
really get only the top half 2/3 of the
plant in that 3d view so I won't spend
too much time talking about specific
indices with hyperspectral imaging
except to say that there are there are a
wide variety of indices that are being
developed using hyper spectral imaging
everything from NDVI
for for remote imaging of fields and
forests to specific indices that measure
things like water chlorophyll and and
stress pigment composition so there's a
lot of discovery potential with with
hyper spec and I think that there's a
lot there's going to be a lot more a lot
more knowledge to be gained using high
perspective in the years ahead we've
recently developed a robotic unit that
will allow us to use hyperspectral
combined with the 3d laser to to get to
translate very complex plant structural
level information into a very
high-resolution 3d model and so this is
a this is a robot it's it's got an
articulating arm that's got
hyperspectral 3d laser scanner and then
two lights that focus into a line and
you're basically doing all of your
imaging and aligned
across the the plant so if the
microphone here is the plant you can
very easily scan up with the robot and
then the articulating arm comes down and
it generates a very high resolution in
three dimensions that way I think that
I'm going to jump through these next
couple of slides because there was one
point that I thought was worth talking
about with this audience and I'm coming
up on time here so Lemna Tech produces
when we're looking at greenhouse when
we're looking at greenhouse level
solutions for phenotyping Lemna Tech
really delivers green greenhouse
phenotyping solutions based on that are
tailored to a research institutions
demand and so at the number Nebraska
innovation campus we have a conveyor
based greenhouse system and we recently
completed at the Cranfield agricultural
engineering precision Innovation Center
a gantry based system and there are
there are a number of pros and cons to
either of these systems that I think are
worth evaluating as you're thinking
about building out infrastructure in
this way so conveyor based systems have
been around for quite a number of years
and in many respects they're very tried
and true way of doing high throughput
Venis I think but some of the drawbacks
of a conveyor system are that you have
lower size and weight limits because of
the intrinsic limits of the conveyor and
also the interns equipments of the
cabinets that you're bringing the plants
through in contrast a gantry system
because the plants don't have to move
but they you're bringing the sensor to
the plants in a gantry system you can
basically phenotype large plants all the
way out to maturity so if you're asking
questions of corn out to v7 then maybe a
conveyor then there may be a conveyor
system is what you want but if you
really want to start asking reproductive
stage questions around corn in a
controlled environment a gantry system
it's probably the solution that you're
looking for
conveyor systems as I said when we were
talking about 3d imaging with the gantry
conveyor systems will give you a
high-resolution whole plant imaging the
the gantry system will be relying on 3d
3d reconstructions and so there you're
getting down to about halfway down the
plant but you won't be able to get all
the way down to the pot now there are
some solutions that you could consider
with sort of imaging within the rows of
a gantry system to supplement your
gantry but from the gantry itself you're
not going to be able to get the entire
plant however with a conveyor system
while you're doing plant level tracking
and analysis which can be very important
for basic for basic research the gantry
system will allow you to do canopy level
analysis so if you're asking for how
things translate more into a field
context the gantry system may be maybe
the way to go
the conveyor system as I'm trying to
communicate down here with this graph is
a fixed configuration so there is some
variation in how you how you can
populate the greenhouse with a conveyor
system but in general your pots are
always going to be this far apart so you
could populate it with every other pot
or you can change your pots so that
there's multiple plants within a carrier
but there's all they're always going to
be in this configuration that's defined
by the conveyor a gantry system it's
wide open so you can configure the floor
of the greenhouse however you want with
the gantry so there's a lot of a lot of
opportunity there however with the
conveyor system the movement really
mitigates any environmental variation
that will occur in any greenhouse so no
matter how good your greenhouse is
there's always going to be environmental
variation and you'll need to take that
into consideration with your
experimental design
with a convey with a gantry system and
yeah one one real quick one another real
quick point in cases where moving your
plant can influence the outcome of the
phenotype obviously a conveyor gantry
system is going to be a better choice so
a real clear example of that is thermal
imaging if you want to do anything with
thermal imaging as soon as you move the
plant on a conveyor you immediately
disrupt your ability to do that in a
biologically relevant way you'll get
data but whether its interpretive all or
meaningful so we all we provide all of
the software for for all of the all of
the instrumentation that I just
described and I also want to give a
shout out here to the plant CV software
which really is it's an open-source
software solution that overlaps a lot
with some of the things that we do with
Lemna grid and there's a lot of really
exciting things happening with with
plant cv these days in the plant
community I think I'll I'll jump to the
end here and just open it up to some
final questions so just to summarize
phenotyping really follows on genotyping
it's it's crucial that we we develop
tools to address this challenge as we
become more capable in our ability to
genotype and make genome modifications
and Lemna tech delivers solutions at a
variety of scales laboratory greenhouse
and fields to do just that so with that
olá
[Applause]
yeah the robot moves around the plant so
there's not a need for the plant to
rotate that way now in the cabinets that
I showed on the conveyer system actually
if you looked at that particular image
there's as the plant moves into those
cabinets that it moves on to a stage
that it lifts it and that rotates so
then you can from a pick from fixed
cameras you can get multiple angle you
can get a variety of different angle yes
so on the robot on the robot there will
be is the plant this is the robot I'm
the robot there will be one camera that
moves around like that in the cabinets
there's two cameras maybe three but the
plant moves so in the cat in the cabinet
configuration so that's what I mean
that's a higher throughput so that that
kind of solution in the cabinet where
you have that's a higher throughput
lower resolution solution to to the to
the problem the robot is specifically a
solution we're developing it's lower
throughput but higher resolution so I'm
the robot well it'll depend on with the
question you're asking but you can
easily you can easily test a green house
if you take a conveyor grease you can
easily test a green house of 500 or even
even the thousand or 2,000 plants in a
day through visible visible light
imaging with that hype with the robotic
unit that's going to be like five to ten
that can be a high perspex lows
everything down no matter whether it's
on a robot or around six mounted high
perspex allows everything down because
you're looking at multiple wave you're
capturing multiple wavelengths that will
be that is probably going to be five to
ten minutes to plant depending on the
type of scan that you do so but you can
do you can get high throughput you can
test an entire green ounce
from an educational standpoint as we
kind of graduate sees what are the
skills that your company most values
great question that's a really great
question so so the data analytics the
data analytics piece developing
developing the computational tools for
handling handling the the massive
amounts of information that we're
generating so that gantry system Chris
might actually be able to answer that
it's generating terabytes of data per
day yeah I mean it's just you know an
enormous so the data data analytics
piece there's really really important to
be able to take the biological know how
I'm bridge it with the instrumentation
that's a that's a that's a really
crucial piece so understanding what the
what the strengths weaknesses limits are
of the image of the sensor
instrumentation that's that that's out
there is is really crucial and I'll
think about that some more and be ready
to talk to grad students at their break
it's a great question this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu